In previous videos, you saw us planning to make
our first Level 2 house on the land.
- The Level 2 house doesn't exist yet,
but just to illustratewhat it could look like:
Something like a shipping container.
- We went to find trailers to transforminto a new home.
We did a vote with our Patreons,
because we didn't know which one to choose...
Thewinner was this old blue pig trailer.
We installed it in the middle land of Project Kamp,
which we stilldon't own...
It was quite an operation to bring it here!
Now, it's time to start working on ourLevel 2 house!
Welcome to a new Project Kamp update!
Here I am in the Middle Land!
Finally, we haveour big trailer here!
Ready to be transformed into a new house!
We are gonna rip it apart to seewhat is the state of things.
We then decide what we can reuse, or what not,
what needssome new work, some welding, some cutting...
So, let's see!
Let me show you a bit more indepth what is inside!
Let's see what is here...
So, here we are inside the trailer.
The idea nowis to check off:
''What can we use and what not?''
''What do we need to take out from here?''
''What can we use?''
''What do we needto cut?''
''What can we reuse?''
''What do we just need to rebuild ourselves?''
We need to deconstruct the pig trailer first.
Then, we need to restore it, and then we can start.
We will start the alreadywith some deconstruction.
Like, we have these bars here...
This is flipped, so they probably reused
this wood already from another different truck.
The state, as you alreadysaw, is a bit how it looks...
We don't have a roof now.
It's just tarp.
It's notreally closing properly, because it's completely wobbly.
This floor used to be wood and metal beams,
but then, someone put this new floor on top.
Probably with the animal transport, it began to rot.
We will see if it's worth to take it apart or not.
Usually, the nuts you can screw out and take it apart.
That's not the case here...
Besides the challenges of the trailer itself...
We also have thechallenges of how to
work here in this environment.
So, we are now in Portugal, and it's summer...
It'squite hot.
This comes with some challenges,
like there's some fire risk around.
Whenwe work with metal tools, grinders, welding...
We're also a bit far from the workspace,
likearound 200 meters from Basekamp.
Which also can create some challenges...
Like, bringing tools up and bringing toolsdown.
We don't have battery tools for everything.
So, we have these little challenges that we
willtry to tackle as best as we can.
Also, we have some new people that
we want to introduce to you!
Some of them you might already seen somewhere.
Some of them maybe you remember from othertimes.
But, let's introduce them properly first!
- Hey! I'm Robert!
I'm 24 years old, and I come fromIceland.
I enjoy country music and physical work.
I have a background in metalworks, butI also like landscaping!
I came to the project to test myself in a new environment--
Fuck! It's hot here!
And, living in a community.
I've been following the project since
Season1, and I'm also a Patreon!
So, it's awesome to experience this firsthand!
I also really enjoy meat, which is really strange that I'm in a vegan Kamp,
but I have no problem with it!
And, if I need my things, I can always go to the nearby town and enjoy!
In the future, I would love to travelto the Southern USA.
Because, I love the people and the culture there.
But, forthe time being, let's get rid of some rust!
- Hey! I am Wouter!
I am a designer, maker, and carpenter from theNetherlands!
I love food, music and nature.
Last year, I developed a big interest insustainable buildings.
I hope to find a way of living less consumeristic,
individualistic, and more close to nature!
I would love to find a good place for my son to grow up.
Lastyear, you could see me building the yoga decks.
This year, I'm designing and building the Level 2 house!
I'm back at Project Kamp to work on positive change,
and get inspired bya different, but same-minded people!
- Now that the people are introduced, we can finally start with the project!
First thing to do: bring electricity tothe trailer!
So, we are here: the workshop in Basekamp.
The pig trailer is here.
Wealready made a path to the pig trailer to bring it in.
But, now, we want to make a shorterpath for the electricity.
Okay! Let's start!
Now you can roll out the cable!
After we connected the electricity from Basekamp to the trailer,
our next step iscleaning the area around the trailer
Reduce the risk of fire during the work.
Finally, we can detach the topfrom the trailer,
and make a nice shaded area with it.
A bit sketchy, but forthe temporary setting is more than enough!
And then, there was shade!
It's maybe still a bit sketchy, but it will work.
Look at all this shade!
- So, now it's time toget rid of the old,
to make room for the new!
We need to take out the wood panels on the side.
But, the bolts and nuts are quite rusty...
We need to find an alternative.
- This was really rusty!
We're cutting off the door!
So, we're gonna do an incision at
the ground level and then topple this.
It will come down!
- We took all the screws out of the wallon the back.
So, we now can tear it down!
What are you up to, Robert?
- We're about to cut off the floor with a big ass grinder!
Because, it's really, really rusted,
and aboutto fall through...
- Do you think this is rusty?
We take this one first I think.
Maybe check if we can lift it up with the bar?
And then, if the floor is loose, we can maybe start on that part?
Then, we go to this part.
- Sounds good!
You ready?
- Yup!
Let'ssee what we find underneath!
The reason why we have the sheet here is
toprevent the sparks from hitting the grass!
So, we don't cause a wildfire or fire...
Becausethen all of the beloved neighbors will most likely lose their lands...
We'll see ProjectKamp start from the beginning, or no start at all.
Come on, Jaime!
- It seems Robert has some welding to do.
Fuck...
That was probably a really good shot!
- So, we want to push it this morning,
and finishall the cutting and the grinding.
Because, as you can see, it's a cloudy morning and foggy.
Andalso, everything is humid, so we can use powertools before 11 AM.
Also, we are using some precautions.
We have water here and a fire extinguisher.
- Why do you do that?
I'm preventing, so that Robert won't cut through the frame.
These Icelandic people are sometimes rough.
- You can see the real big beam can carry a lotof weight!
It goes all the way from the front to the back.
Then, we have wood.
And then, there are someO-shaped beams here,
that carry the wooden beams.
On the edge, you can that the wood is bit rotten.
There is quite some rust.
I think we need to do something with this...
For the rest, all seemed quite okay.
A few bad spots in the middle,
but we must be able to carryquite some load.
Here, we have the most rusty bit of the trailer.
Some really big holes...
Rotten wood...
Here is the beam at the bottom on the side.
It's really the wood next to it that is really bad...
Also, the steelis pretty rusty,
so we have to take the wood out.
To make sure that we can protectthis side,
against any future damage.
- What are we gonna start doingRobert?
We are cleaning the frame, so we can get most of the paint
andrust off, just so we can repaint it again.
After we cleared the rust, we needed to do a better welding.
So, we took down the machine and the generator to the trailer,
because our solaris not enough for welding.
But then...
- Hey Robert!
What's up, Javi?
- Do you know where the weldingshots from the pig trailer?
No?
I think I forgot to take them?
- The life of avideo maker...
Anyway, you can see the results in the photos they've took.
They seemsturdy enough!
Okay, so now, let's take out the backdoors.
- We want to takethese doors out,
but the hinges are connected with one big piece of metal.
We are going to take it out at once.
We are gonna cut this hinge here and here,
and just hammer the upper part out and this one out.
Hopefully, we can get the door out.
Easy!
The first door is out -- let's go for the second one!
- The bar is like bended.
We cancut here, and take this out.
It's not moving at all...
It's stuck, and I don't know where it's stuck.
- So, we made a thousand shots.
We've ran into someissues, but the doors are out!
- So, now we're gonna clean the metal,
degreaseit and then paint it.
Luckily, today, we have some help from General Help: Constanceand Alon
We're gonna get good progress today!
- Chester is working hard as always.
Okay, so, we just finished prepping the whole frame!
Thanks Patreon for this amazing experience...
Now, we can focus on painting the whole thing.
We found the same color of paint!
We will see what we do with the floor, after paintingeverything.
Still thinking about it...
Maybe, we redo the whole floor, or we build the floor on it?
So, yeah, for now, it's painting time!
- Let's go!
Let's go!
We're going to start with this side.
It's alot of work!
All these little corners here and bars.
- What are we doing, Jaime?
Good morning, I got an early start.
We are clearing all the rust and pieces
that fell off the trailer on the floor.
And also, we have a bunch of materials here
thatwe really can't use.
We have some of them that we can use that we're gonna try
and make somethingout of it.
But, we also have wood that we can't use anymore,
or metal that's all rusted out.
I think we have to make a few trips
to the waste facility and throw it away.
Then, clear everything under the trailer,
like all the rust and stuff that fell onthe floor.
- So, dear camera, we're now going on an adventure
to find a place where we can drop this stuff off.
So, somebody told us about this new place
toget rid of metal.
It's a cool place!
They weigh the car when you come in.
You leave yourstuff, and then they weigh the car again.
They pay youfor the metal!
- So, for 580 kilos of metal, we got 116 euros.
Not bad!
We recovered somecash, and now this material will be recycled.
We had to do a few trips back to the place.
But, after that, it was onlysome wood left to get rid of.
- Watch out!
''In 3rd place, we have the trampoline jumper from France: Colleen!''
- We loaded up the pickup and took it to thelocal waste facility.
Now, we have the place cleared.
We need to get some solid materials
torenovate the trailer, and we need your help tochoose.
So, we went to the scrapyard to search materials,
and it's actually not easy to find good recycled materials here...
But, we found thisstack of old Trespa,
used for promotional stands or something.
It should be sturdy enough for the outside,
but the colors are a bit intense.
But, hey: you can't always choose when recycling!
So, we want to use this,
and we made a few coloroptions to choose from.
If you support us on Patreon,
you can vote for which color we shouldpick.
Sign up on Patreon to vote,
and we will do whatever comes out of it.
But, for now, we first need to prepare ourselves for the rebuild!
- So, we're gonna start with the build of the Level 2 house.
But, right now, we are bringing all the tools up
and down every day and working here.
So, we want to make likea little workstation down there.
I just came from the sawmill, and bought some chestnut beams.
I'm gonnamake two new horses, to make a new workbench
to work down there, and just leave the tools downthere.
Just so we won't struggle with bringing
everything back and forth every day.
So, yeah, I'm just gonna startprocessing
and cutting all the beams to size.
All the cuts are done.
So, it's time for this guy again.
Sometimes I like sanding, but...
Most of the time is just pain in the ass, and today,
it is a pain in the ass...
But, yeah, it's worth it!
I just finished sanding the inner faces of the horses.
So, right now, I'm going to put them together,
and then Ican sand the front and the back.
Right here, you can see the difference of sanding and routing,
and not sanding and routing the edges.
For me, it makes sense to take a bit moretime.
Because, the difference is pretty big.
Okay, so, they just delivered the two toppieces!
This is the second one.
That's some normal multiplex,
so it's going to be the downside.
This isa special multiplex for outside with a corrugated face.
That's gonna prevent everything
from moving around, or at least a bit.
I'm gonna cut the holes in here to put thosein place.
Then, I will screw them together, I think.
The last thing I want to do is to cover thisexposed edge of plywood.
Just so that the water can't get into it.
So, yeah, I'm gonna use a leftoverbeam of chestnut,
cut it to size, and screw it all around the edges.
It's a snug fit, so...
- Yeah, Iremember it from last time.
So, now, the restoring part is ready!
We have ripped itapart:
the rotten things away.
We took the things we are not gonna use.
We sanded it and we repainted it.
Wehave brush cut around to keep it easier to work around,
and also reduce the fire risk we have,when working in such a thing.
We also build a new working station here!
We have put the tarp ontop to be protected from the weather.
We brought electricity from Basekamp.
We brought our tools!
Webuilt a brand new workbench!
In the next video, we will show you what a day
looks like in Project Camp,just in one shot!
If you want to watch it already, you can support us on Patreon!
Otherwise, you canalways make suggestions
and comments on YouTube.
That always helps the algorithm too.
So, that's it!
Seeyou in the next update!
- Another one!